hello and welcome I can go before you am
playing suck my [ __ ] well that's a very
new account yeah eight blitz games okay
so what is he going to do I wasn't
successful some again some some games go
with this opening line so going to a
catalan by transposition and this is
very hopefully not a cheat again like
the guy before
oh my god I really find it funny
sometimes they're like that day I really
don't have anything better to do then
she get an online chat side sorry oops
anyway yeah I reported this guy and I
hope he will be banned quickly then the
leech has mods quite quite quick with
those things and also quite not sure if
reliable is the word but kind of I think
they they banned every single person
that reported I think they did so it's
not like I'm reporting everybody that I
feel okay that wasn't like some people
scream cheating every single time they
lose a game this is of course wrong but
guess in some cases are so damn obvious
like if it okay what do you think okay
anyway so let's see we have a bi trans
position gotten into a stonewalled setup
trans position is maybe a wrong wrong
way to phrase it
because it's probably not a position
that you would get from a stone wall
like particularly this this one
but I mean it's not a move order
whatever it's just the the same
structure I'm trying to open this ham
with age three I don't feel that black
setup here's all that healthy oh wow
really hmm interesting
I thought maybe that is wrong
that I can just use the H file myself
now by taking this is probably this is
not such an easy thing let's do it
I thought like he would probably take
with the night and I will get the H far
right I mean there are some things that
are in play here I thought I have 90s g4
here maybe I'm wrong but I thought that
this is this is on yeah that must work
right I mean why shouldn't it work I
because he's got Queen g5 on how utterly
stupid I totally I completely overlooked
he's got Queen to g5 or should Wow
that's stupid
at least it's not taking immediately so
maybe this is kind of a bluff that would
that works
I completely forgot that it's got Queen
g5y and now him now he he went for it
okay maybe this is making it a bit more
difficult than at least I've got booked
rook h5
here it was an idea that was my idea
behind ruk h1 that this Queen g5 does
not work that easily
night xg4 was a huge blunder really
is giving up giving up the Queen that's
a good decision it's a good decision
because now my position is very um it
doesn't have any any sort of harmony and
f2 is hanging oh my I'm still in I'm
still in bad shape
Wow very bad shape
it's it's totally lost really Wow Wow
what is the way to fight him though
Bishop Sam Bishop d6 if possible Bishop
d6 now is a good move I hope if he takes
it I can take the rook and I have Bishop
e5 coming mmm that makes it at least a
little bit trickier I think for him yeah
that's probably a good move
so going to check you know how do I get
do I get closer to his king somehow yeah
I would need I totally I can take it
well I mean I was thinking I would
looked at but okay I had covered g3 I
didn't do it to that stupid him so much
check with this even though he blundered
this rook in one move it's still not so
easy walk f2 is going to be very
dangerous
it's still it's so it's still not easy I
know look afterwards i'm happy about
this if that happens instead of threat
work g3
okay now this is the moment he's he
doesn't have a check at the moment how
do I get something going him this one
for loop takes G for group t3 chick oh
it's too bad it's too bad
I need to make a quick decision I didn't
have any time and I did it's not good
Jim really isn't good
King III is probably winning all this
also my twin ago okay okay I got this
pawn at least I'm still lost and he
found it there would be two yeah it's
it's fair that I lose the game somehow
even though I might was out of it at
some point I don't know I mean this was
a was of course a gross blunder but it
was still not easy for white not at all
very very odd game I mean it was it was
very very badly played ya know a lot of
cheat no like two in a row no no that
was not a cheat at all I mean he got I
completely outplayed him yeah with with
all this it was quite clear that that
happened Knight takes d4 is just a
terrible move I just have to do
something normal him yeah
I'd simply had there was just a total
blind spot Queen g5 so what should I do
we take on d5 or Knight h5m there's
something like that and rook h1 which
I'm just having an attack there this is
just a bad move Andrew Queen g5 I don't
think he intended the Queen sacrifice at
this point but it is obviously very
strong as we saw yeah he has to do it
now I mean it is he was basically forced
to do it as and everything else I take
here and win so yeah technically
so Knight h5 again yeah sorry
what should i do there Queenie - yeah
okay I mean 94 is just a big blunder so
okay here rook g5 questionable yeah
whatever I cannot do really much else
Bishop a three double question okay okay
it's lost anyway Queen g1 nope this is
the only move to make a little bit of a
fight out of it okay here we have three
wins yeah but okay it's the only winning
for black anyhow and this is Ruchi
three-eighths is simply blundered that
one but the funny thing is that it is
still on very difficult and he did a
good job there if five is a good move
opening everything up I have Bishop f4 I
try to I try to give some material back
to make it easier to play with hindsight
I should probably really play Queen c2
as the engine says or some some move
Queen e1 to cover have to ya but I'm
quite I'm kind of okay with what I did
here which is difficult to do and yeah
here Bishop f5 you know best was CD 5
okay I've got Queen to b5 no Luke h8
what yeah I mean it's it's extremely
difficult to play the same look f1 is
better yeah whatever it's already lost
them so I didn't have any any chance it
didn't give me any chance they're right
I wasn't totally certain if maybe there
was a way to like win the bonus or
something like that um yeah okay Knight
xg4 was just very silly
I was just quite silly and here the
computer wants to know it actually likes
a knight takes Bishop takes e4 after
some calculation now I don't think this
was particularly bad you know computer
wants to take first on d5 I'm not sure
if that makes a huge difference yeah I
mean why does the white is certainly
better you're just Knight takes d4 is
very stupid anyway thanks for watching